Transcription: Louise Bouchart
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
(Chants d’orques)
Vous entendez ?
C’est une conversation entre des êtres
dont le langage et la culture diffèrent
selon les régions et les tribus,
où chaque individu dans sa langue
a une signature vocale,
à l’usage d’un prénom, comme nous.
Bonjour, je m'appelle Muriel Arnal.
Toute petite, mon grand-père
m’emmenait découvrir la Nature
et m’apprenait le chant
des oiseaux, en Corrèze.
À dix ans,
choquée par la vision déchirante
d’un éléphant dans le camion d’un cirque,
je suis venue chaque jour
le voir et lui apporter à manger.
Ces deux moments de ma jeune vie
me firent réaliser
ce qui était une évidence :
je consacrerai ma vie aux animaux
et à les défendre.
C’est ainsi que j’ai créé «One Voice»
il y a près de trente ans.
Je viens, aujourd’hui,
vous parler des orques,
ces monuments
d’intelligence et de solidarité.
Pour beaucoup, elles sont les plus
grands prédateurs de la planète,
mais elles sont tellement plus.
Elles utilisent des dialectes
identifiés et différents
selon les groupes
auxquels elles appartiennent.
On associe également à chaque tribu
des cultures véritables.
Le degré d’évolution des orques
est extraordinaire,
entre celui des humains
et de nos cousins les grands singes.
Leurs émotions,
leur niveau de conscience
sont si complexes
qu’ils restent un mystère.
Les groupes d'orques sont menés
par une matriarche.
Eh oui, c’est une
grand-mère qui les guide,
pour la chasse aux otaries par échouage
en Argentine pour une tribu,
pour la chasse aux grands requins blancs
au large de la Californie pour une autre,
et puis, des orques qui ne se nourrissent
que de petits poissons.
Le cerveau des orques
contient des neurones en fuseaux.
Ces neurones sont responsables
de l’empathie et de la vie sociale.
Ils sont très rares dans le règne animal.
Et elles ont un sixième sens :
l’écholocation.
Grâce aux sons, elles voient sous l'eau.
Elles sont les animaux
les plus sophistiqués de la planète,
en termes d'acoustique.
En comparaison, nous sommes
probablement primitifs.
Des chercheurs ont étudié leur langage et
découvert un monde particulièrement évolué
que nous ne sommes toujours pas
en mesure de comprendre aujourd’hui.
Les signaux sonores des orques
sont organisés de manière très complexe.
Il y a, par exemple, une ponctuation,
des abréviations, des syllabes,
des préfixes, des suffixes,
en résumé, une communication très
élaborée et qui diffère selon les tribus.
Et puis, il y a cette conscience
collective si particulière.
Le système limbique,
c’est la zone du cerveau
responsable de l’olfaction, de la mémoire,
et de la régulation des émotions.
Celui des cétacés est très développé
et beaucoup plus volumineux que le nôtre,
au point qu’un lobe supplémentaire dit
« paralimbique » pénètre dans leur cortex.
Les orques ont ce lobe supplémentaire
et, comme vous l’avez vu,
les circonvolutions de leur cerveau
sont plus complexes que les nôtres.
D’après la Docteure Lori Marino,
qui est professeure en neurosciences
et spécialiste des cétacés,
il entraîne une fusion
sans équivalent connu
entre émotions et cognition -
probablement un mélange
de communication et de conscience
que nous ne comprenons pas.
Cette structure pourrait être impliquée
dans une conscience collective.
Oui, vous avez bien entendu :
une conscience collective,
un sens du soi partagé
qui expliquerait notamment qu’aucune orque
ne puisse abandonner l’une des siennes,
et qu’il lui soit
si difficile d’en être séparée.
Les orques,
c’est évidemment la solidarité.
En 2014, en Nouvelle-Zélande,
Diane s’est retrouvée coincée
par la ligne d’un casier de pêche.
Le temps que les secours arrivent,
ses deux fils l’ont soutenue et aidée
à monter à la surface pour respirer,
alors qu’elle était épuisée.
Et Diane est toujours en vie aujourd’hui.
Au large de l’Afrique du Sud,
c’est une toute jeune orque
qui avait été grièvement blessée
par l’hélice d’un bateau
et était restée
gravement handicapée.
Elle fut prise en charge par sa famille.
À 14 ans, elle avait la taille
d’une orque de deux ans,
mais vivait très entourée.
Et par exemple, pendant la chasse,
elle restait à l’écart,
toujours avec une orque
à ses côtés, son grand frère,
pour la protéger
des attaques des requins.
Et après la chasse,
sa famille partageait
la nourriture avec elle,
comme c’est la règle
au sein des tribus d’orques.
En liberté, les orques ne s’entretuent pas
et ne se blessent jamais gravement.
Malgré la compétition pour les proies
et l’accouplement, malgré les désaccords,
leurs règles sociales
interdisent la violence.
Elles ont trouvé comment répartir
pacifiquement les ressources
entre les différents groupes.
Nous aurions certainement
quelques choses à apprendre d’elles...
J’ai eu la chance de rencontrer
des orques remarquables,
une rencontre qui touche
à l’âme et au cœur
avec les orques Résidentes du Sud.
C’est une tribu piscivore et sédentaire
auprès de laquelle les marsouins
et les dauphins aiment nager
car ils se sentent en sécurité quand
ils croisent d’autres tribus d’orques.
Les Résidentes du Sud vivent au large
de l’État de Washington dans le Pacifique,
et leur mode de vie sédentaire a permis
aux scientifiques de les étudier.
Namu fut la première orque
à être capturée en 1961,
car il se refusait à abandonner un petit
prisonnier d’un filet de pêche.
Donc, il a suivi le bateau,
fut ensuite capturé
et ramené jusqu’à Seattle
à l’aide d’un enclos flottant,
suivi de près par sa famille,
quarante orques,
qui ont échangé continuellement avec lui
jusqu’à sa mort, après un an de captivité.
À partir de cette période, elles ont
été décimées par les delphinariums.
Oui, plus de cinquante d’entre elles
ont été capturées,
sans compter celles qui sont mortes
au moment de la violente
séparation des familles.
Et aujourd'hui, une autre menace s'abat
sur cette tribu déjà si fragilisée.
Les Résidentes du Sud meurent de faim
car il n’y a plus de saumon
dans cette zone
hier encore si riche de vie.
À la fin de l’été 2018,
Tahlequah a mis au monde un bébé,
décédé une demi-heure plus tard.
Depuis la côte, on a pu observer
sa famille l’entourer
et faire un cercle
autour du petit, éclairé par la lune.
Tahlequah a ensuite refusé
de laisser partir sa fille,
et pendant 17 jours, elle a porté
sa dépouille, protégée par les siens.
Jamais une telle scène
n’avait été vue auparavant.
Et les scientifiques,
qui étudient les Résidentes du Sud depuis
plus de 40 ans et vivent auprès d’elles,
y ont vu un appel à l’aide.
L’année suivante,
c’est la mère de Tahlequah
qui à son tour, est morte de faim.
Princesse Angeline n'avait que 42 ans.
Par exemple, Granny,
la matriarche du groupe,
a vécu, elle, au-delà de ses 102 ans.
Et on a vu Ocean Sun nager
avec un nouveau-né de sa famille -
Ocean Sun a 94 ans.
Tahlequah a mis au monde
un bébé à nouveau.
Il se porte bien,
mais l’avenir reste sombre.
Les Résidentes du Sud
sont en voie d’extinction.
Imaginez un village dont on aurait volé
tous les enfants pendant une décennie.
Comment se remettre d’un tel traumatisme ?
Et vous allez me demander,
mais pourquoi leur infliger cela ?
Uniquement pour notre amusement,
pour qu’on aille les voir faire les beaux
dans des piscines contre de la nourriture.
Dans les années 1960,
nous ne les connaissions pas,
mais aujourd’hui nous savons,
et on peut encore les sauver,
et en leur portant secours,
nous contribuerons à protéger l’océan.
Un avenir paisible est possible aussi
pour les orques captives.
Au-delà de la souffrance des individus,
la captivité a contribué à chosifier
ces merveilleux animaux.
Le jeune public des bassins
est moins enclin que les autres
à les protéger dans la Nature.
Cette réalité est, par exemple,
inscrite noir sur blanc
dans les Accords Méditerranée
signés par la France.
C’est pourquoi il faut fermer
les delphinariums
et offrir aux orques captives une vraie
vie dans des sanctuaires marins,
ces zones protégées dans des bras de mer
où elles retrouveront enfin les courants,
les marées, la richesse de la vie océane,
où elles pourront nager
en ligne droite et plonger profond,
comme le font les orques libres.
Ces sanctuaires marins
permettront également
de mieux faire connaître les orques,
de montrer que, malgré
leur taille et leur intelligence,
elles sont fragiles et ont besoin de nous.
Le documentaire Blackfish a créé un séisme
au sein de l’industrie de la captivité
et mis à genoux la puissante
entreprise américaine SeaWorld.
Il raconte l’histoire de Tilikum,
depuis sa capture
jusqu’à la troisième attaque mortelle
contre une dresseuse.
Dans la Nature, aucune attaque d’orque
sur un humain n’a jamais été observée.
Le jour de la capture,
poursuivi par des bateaux,
le groupe se sépare en deux.
Les mâles tentent une diversion
tandis que les femelles
prennent discrètement un autre
chemin avec leurs petits.
Mais, repérées par un avion,
elles sont prises en chasse et piégées,
et assistent impuissantes
à la capture de leurs bébés.
À Marineland à Antibes,
des orques sont prisonnières
depuis la fin des années 1960.
Clovis, arrivé là en 1970,
était une orque Résidente du Sud.
Il y est décédé trois ans plus tard.
Aujourd’hui, elles sont
au nombre de quatre
dont Inouk, le plus âgé,
et pourtant si jeune.
Il a eu 23 ans en février dernier.
On peut l’observer
en train de flotter, inerte,
pendant de longues périodes
entre les shows.
Le pire pour ces animaux, c'est l'ennui.
Imaginez être enfermé
24 heures sur 24 dans une pièce vide,
ne rien avoir à faire,
sauf quelques exercices,
toujours les mêmes.
Inouk n’a plus de dents.
comme beaucoup d’orques captives,
il a rongé le béton du bassin
jusqu’à découvrir la pulpe
de ses dents, si sensible.
Des experts parmi les meilleurs mondiaux
ont rédigé, à notre demande,
un rapport sur les dents d’Inouk.
Ce sont des scientifiques qui ont étudié
la dentition de 60 orques en captivité,
publications à l'appui.
D’après eux, Inouk est l’orque qui a la
mâchoire en plus mauvais état au monde.
Il souffre en continu.
Aucune orque, dans aucun
delphinarium dans le monde,
n’est jamais morte de vieillesse, jamais !
Toujours de maladie.
Ce que les gens vont voir,
ce sont des orques en train de mourir.
Nos enfants méritent mieux.
En France, une loi a été
votée l'an dernier.
Je n'entrerai pas dans le détail.
Elle interdit à terme
la captivité des cétacés.
On aurait pu s’en réjouir,
mais un petit ajout
rend le texte inopérant.
La loi interdit la captivité des cétacés,
sauf pour des études scientifiques.
Et devinez qui a déjà des programmes
scientifiques en place ?
Les delphinariums.
Ces études n’ont aucune utilité
pour protéger les orques dans la Nature,
contrairement à ce que clament les parcs.
On peut éventuellement
étudier les animaux captifs,
dans les delphinariums,
mais pour connaître les orques,
il faut étudier celles qui sont libres.
Les orques sont un trésor.
Elles font partie du patrimoine
commun de l’humanité.
Nous avons encore tant à apprendre
de ces êtres si puissants
qui cohabitent entre tribus
sans jamais se faire la guerre.
Il y a urgence à protéger
les orques libres.
Les orques captives, elles, doivent être
transférées dans des sanctuaires marins.
Et le premier de ces refuges pourrait être
un projet français pour nos orques,
porté par « One Voice » avec l’appui
de tous les experts mondiaux.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)